look we're we're both type a competitive
people we've both had success in our
lives and that success at least early on
in earlier phases of our our you know
respective careers was driven in large
part by self-will right like I'm going
to do this I am self-reliant I'm taking
responsibility for my path uh I can't
rely on anyone else and I'm going to
buckle down I might not be the fastest
or the smartest but I'm going to outwork
that person and you quickly realize when
you get results doing that that you can
leap frog over people um but if you're
also uh harboring an addiction um you
can use that facility that you have to
rationalize your behavior because as
long as you're waking up at 4:00 in the
morning to go running or you're meeting
your deadlines at work and you're
graduating sumacum ly and all of these
things you can then say well I don't
really have a problem and it perpetuates
the condition that then just continues
to like foment and grow